[Música]
las mujeres del mundo se unieron en un
solo reclamo para lograr la igualdad de
derechos y condiciones laborales entre
otros pedidos todo esto en el marco de
la conmemoración del día internacional
de la mujer en México por ejemplo las
mujeres de diferentes minorías pidieron
ser visibilizadas mientras que en
Argentina exigieron equidad laboral
y llegaron a la ciudad de Rosario en
Argentina los 1.400 tropas de la policía
y del ejército en un intento del
gobierno del presidente Alberto
Fernández de mitigar la escalada de
violencia reciente y también el impacto
que tienen los grupos ligados al
narcotráfico los agentes llegarán allí
en medio de reclamos ciudadanos por
seguridad en las zonas residenciales
y en Estados Unidos el departamento de
Justicia presentó un informe en el que
responsabiliza a la policía de la ciudad
de Louisville de ejercer violencia
sistemática contra la población
afroamericana este informe tiene lugar
después de dos años de haber iniciado
Las investigaciones debido a la muerte
de la joven Bruno Taylor
Bienvenidos a este informativo de France
24 en el que hacemos un resumen de las
noticias más destacadas de nuestro
continente el continente americano vamos
a comenzar en el norte en México en
medio de gritos pancartas y pañoletas
moradas miles de mujeres marcharon por
la emblemática avenida Paseo de la
Reforma en la capital mexicana para
conmemorar el Día Internacional de la
mujer que sirvió para reclamar a las
autoridades Por la alta tasa de
feminicidios que presenta México las
manifestaciones y las manifestantes
algunas de las participantes allí
representan a diferentes minorías y a
grupos históricamente discriminados y
allí pidieron visibilidad también en
pacientes oncológicas se unieron como
grupo para ser parte de esta marcha del
8m desde Ciudad de México marinas ardiña
nos cuenta más
miles de mujeres han vuelto a las calles
en Ciudad de México en el Día
Internacional de la mujer para
reivindicar entre otras cosas el cese de
las múltiples violencias que sufren a
diario cada dos horas una mujer es
asesinada en México 2022 cumplió el
trágico récord de más de tres mil
setecientos homicidios de mujeres sin
embargo solo el 33,7% de estos
asesinatos son investigados como
feminicidios y más del 90% quedan en la
impunidad Pese a que cada día en México
10 mujeres son asesinadas por el mero
hecho de ser mujer
Yo vengo porque soy sobreviviente de
feminicidio y pido justicia para que me
agresor tenga una condena ejemplar y las
carpetas se arreglan como deben de ser
para que él pague lo que hizo las
reivindicaciones en esta jornada son
extensas las manifestantes también salen
a las calles por la paridad
institucional laboral y económica La
Brecha salarial entre mujeres y hombres
en México es del
34%, más datos el 98% de las mexicanas
han sufrido acoso y hostigamiento en el
transporte público y México es el
segundo país de América Latina con peor
inserción laboral para las mujeres
salimos a marchar las compañeras que
estamos representando a la científicas
porque siempre dicen que las feministas
con aquellas que están en la ciencia o
en la academia justamente porque
queremos hacer una ciencia y una
academia diferente queremos hacer una
academia En donde ya no se replican
estas prácticas machistas Y en donde
todas estemos incluidas el gobierno
mexicano ha desplegado más de 800
policías mujeres también ha blindado
edificios y estatuas mientras que aquí
en las calles de México las mujeres
compartas arengas y cánticos han vuelto
a teñir las calles del color de los
Jacarandas y nos vamos hasta Argentina
allí a pesar de las altas temperaturas
por el verano las mujeres y diferentes
colectivos también marcharon en
diferentes ciudades del país para exigir
equidad laboral y terminar con la
violencia de género así como pedir una
mejor repartición de las labores de
Cuidado históricamente estas marchas en
Argentina que tienen como marco el Día
Internacional de la mujer han servido
para que las mujeres argentinas logren
avances legislativos Como por ejemplo la
ley que permite la interrupción del
embarazo natalio cosoil corresponsal de
France 24 en la ciudad de Buenos Aires
estuvo en esta marcha allí en la capital
Argentina justo enfrente de la Sede del
Congreso y este es su reporte
como todos los años frente al congreso
de la nación argentina se lleva a cabo
esta convocatoria por el Día
Internacional de la mujer aquí en la
ciudad de Buenos Aires es una de las
muchas que se llevan a cabo en toda
Argentina este año hay un reclamo muy
fuerte en torno a la equidad laboral la
falta de equidad laboral y a la
violencia de género también una
exigencia de que se incorpore la
perspectiva de género definitivamente en
el ámbito de la justicia y que se
repartan de mejor forma a las tareas de
Cuidado Pero además recordemos que
movilizaciones como esta del Ocho hoy me
fueron las que lograron con La potencia
de la calle que el congreso aprobara en
el año 2020 la ley del aborto legal
seguro y gratuito en Argentina algo que
también se está reclamando que se
implemente correcta Y definitivamente en
esta marcha que tiene lugar este 8 de
marzo en la ciudad de Buenos Aires
[Música]
y seguimos en Argentina porque las 1400
tropas de la policía y del ejército
nacional llegaron a la ciudad de Rosario
para intentar combatir la oleada de
violencia que asola a esa ciudad el
presidente Alberto Fernández también
prometió acondicionar los barrios
dignamente
es una declaración de guerra del
gobierno argentino contra las bandas
criminales en la ciudad de Rosario con
el envío de 1400 tropas tras una oleada
de inseguridad y violencia generada por
las redes de narcotráfico hemos traído
fuerzas federales lo suficientemente
importante como para actuar en cada uno
de los lugares porque hemos venido a
hacer eso a trabajar sin sin destajo y
sin ningún tipo de cortapisas para
llegar al fondo de la cuestión su
objetivo rastrear los barrios y allanar
los domicilios que sean necesarios para
acabar con las estructuras criminales
si bien el problema de la violencia en
Rosario viene de largo todo escalo con
el asesinato de un niño de 11 años
máximo Jerez en medio de un fuego
cruzado en el barrio de Los Pumas
causando indignación entre los vecinos
que se sienten desprotegidos y exigen
acción del gobierno ahora la madre de
Máximo solo pide una cosa que no le
vuelva a pasar algo así a ningún otro
niño del barrio
máximo
los familiares y amigos de la víctima
intentaron tomarse la justicia por su
mano irrumpieron en la casa del supuesto
narcotraficante responsable acusando la
falta de acción gubernamental en lo que
según reconoció el propio Ministerio de
seguridad es una zona controlada por las
bandas ilegales situación tras la que el
mismo presidente Alberto Fernández
prometió actuar Vamos a ponerle fin a la
violencia criminal de sicarios
mercaderes de la muerte en lo que va de
2023 al menos 65 personas han muerto en
medio de tiroteos en Rosario en una
guerra entre bandas por el control de
los puntos de venta de droga que afecta
a los más pobres y a la que ahora el
gobierno quiere poner a fin volvemos al
norte del continente en Estados Unidos
el departamento de Justicia presentó un
informe que responsabiliza la policía de
la ciudad de Louisville de ejercer
violencia sistemática contra la
población afroamericana esto tiene lugar
dos años después de una investigación
por el asesinato de briona Taylor
un pronunciamiento sin precedentes por
parte del departamento de justicia de
Estados Unidos
el departamento ha concluido que existe
una causa razonable para creer que en
lushville metro y la policía
metropolitana se involucraron en un
patrón o práctica de conducta que viola
la primera y cuarta enmienda de la
Constitución
Esta es la principal conclusión de las
autoridades tras Investigar los hechos
detrás de la muerte de la joven
afroamericana briona Taylor asesinada
por la policía durante una redada el 13
de marzo de 2020 el departamento de
Justicia es Claro en señalar que las
actuaciones de la policía son
sistemáticamente discriminatorias contra
la población afroamericana estos
hallazgos justificaron la decisión Del
fiscal general de poner fin a las
restricciones sobre los decretos de
consentimiento que impedían
responsabilizar a los departamentos de
Justicia locales ahora la fiscalía
general estadounidense se sentará a
negociar con la fiscalía y la policía de
Luis vil un acuerdo de consentimiento
este acuerdo con promedio a la ciudad y
a la fiscalía de Louisville a trabajar
con la fiscalía general la comunidad Los
oficiales de la policía y otras partes
interesadas para abordar los problemas
que hemos identificado
la eventual firma de este consentimiento
entre autoridades locales y federales es
un paso importante para combatir la
violencia policial sistemática en
Estados Unidos contra la población negra
y una esperanza para que casos como el
de briona Taylor George Floyd y decenas
más no se repitan
es todo por el momento aquí en las
noticias de France 24 siga con nosotros
[Música]